Hi, I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters. Thanks for requesting a download of my book, Stop Fighting Cancer, and Start Treating the Cause.
Over the last several years, I've offered this book online and have had literally thousands of downloads from all over the world.
But I discovered a problem.
When you are a loved one or diagnosed with cancer, it can be a very scary thing.
You can be bombarded with information from a variety of different sources.
And I know that this is a lot of data as well, and I don't want to contribute to you being overwhelmed.
So instead of simply giving you my book, I'm going to give you a program.
I've divided this book into small, bite-sized pieces, and added specific topics that will help you along your journey.
With each section, you'll receive a short video similar to this that will help explain the material.
I know you have many difficult decisions to make, and I want this program to be a blessing to help you move forward.
And always, if you have any questions, call by personal assistant immediately.